Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, although most people
know me as Rawkode across the Internet.
Today is an episode of Rawkode live where
we take a look at open source software
to see how it can help make our
day to day lives a little bit easier
and what is a vast, evolving, and complex
ecosystem.
Today, we're taking a look at feature flagging
using feature flagging. Feature flagging is an a
project called Flipt, and I am joined by
Mark and George.
Hey, guys. How's it going?
Hey. Hey. Good. How are you?
Oh, thanks. Nobody ever does that.
Yeah.
Do they know?
Yeah. I'm I'm actually doing alright. I've been
a little bit stressed this week because I
missed a few days food poisoning. But, you
know, it's nice to be back in front
of our camera playing with some pretty cool
software again.
Now for the people watching, before we even
talk about what a flag on a feature
is, can you both tell us a little
bit more about you? And let's just do
it clockwise. So we'll start with you, George.
Off you go.
Cool. Yeah. Cool. Hey. I'm George. I work
on Flipt, unsurprisingly,
with Mark. I'm
based in in The UK in a city
called Brighton,
just South of London.
Yeah.
I've been working with working with Mark on
this for last year.
And
yeah. I used to work with Mark some
years ago, that's how we came together again
to to tackle feature flags. Yeah.
That's me. Alright. Thank you very much. Mark?
Yeah.
So I'm Mark. I'm the founder of
and I am based in Raleigh, North Carolina
on the East Coast US.
And so as George alluded to, we have
been working together on this for about a
year.
I
worked on it for a few years before
this, kind of a as a side project.
Before going full time on Flipt, I was
at GitHub for about three years.
And then before that, I was at a
company called Code Shift, which is where George
and I worked and met.
We worked together for about two and a
half years, I think.
Wow. So you're, like, moving
up the stack instead of down the stack.
Right? So you did CICD, then you went
to get hosting, which I guess is down
the stack, and now you went, no. Fuck
that. Let's go to feature flags and you've
been straight back up the top.
Yep. Just all of it.
All of the best. Well, I'm assuming,
you know,
user engineers,
she's a smart people, you find problems you
like to solve them. So I'd love to
learn more about how you got into, like,
the position where you were sitting there and
going, you know, tea, coffee, beer, whatever it
may be.
Let's fix feature flags. Like, me a bit
about the background.
Yeah.
I had, like, always been kind of enamored
with feature flags ever since I, like, learned
about them. You know, it's not one of
those things that they taught in university or
at least they did when I went, to
university.
And,
you know, I really was introduced to them
kind of midway through my career,
at another
startup I worked at.
Anyways and I realized, like, the power of
feature flags and how, like, you can just,
you know, basically separate your releases of your
software from deployments and easily respond to incidents
and, you know, test things and production and
all that good stuff.
And, you know, one thing I I realized
as my career progressed
was, you know, I saw
these companies starting to use feature flags.
And another thing I saw, though, was that
everyone was kind of reinventing their reinventing the
wheel and and writing feature flag software themselves.
And so I think at
three or four of the last companies I
worked at, each one of them had an
in house feature flag solution.
And I thought, you know, this is kinda
crazy. Like, why would everyone like, I realized,
you know, from the outset, feature flags don't
seem that complicated. So it's like, okay. We'll
just put something in the database,
and, you know, it's just an if else
statement, and we'll just create some APIs.
But as time progresses,
you know, people build up
features on top of these feature flag solutions,
and they just kind of lead to sprawl
and
a lot of a lot of
extra things that you don't think about from
the start. And I was like, it doesn't
make sense to me that
companies are spending their engineering resources
on implementing their own feature flag solution when
that that's not even
what the company sells. You know? That's not
what their bread and butter is. Right? So
it just seemed like wasted effort.
And even at GitHub, hopefully, I'm not giving
away any secrets, but, GitHub, you know, as
big as it is, you know, it's at
the end of the day, a big Rails
monolith. That's what you see when you log
in to github.com. Obviously, there's all these external
services now, like Codespaces and Copilot and GitHub
Package Registry and all this stuff, but they
still interface with the monolith
for getting feature flag data.
And
the solution that GitHub uses or at least
they used when I was there was a
Ruby gem
called Fliptr
that they built on top of throughout the
ten plus years that GitHub has been around.
And so they basically built their own feature
flag solution,
but in order to make it scale and
make it accessible for all these external services,
they had to end up, like, creating internal
APIs,
poking holes in firewalls,
and creating clients in all these different languages
now that GitHub uses.
And I just thought that's crazy that there's
this group of engineers who maintains this feature
flag solution at GitHub
when they could be doing, you know, a
lot of a ton of other different things.
And so that was kind of the impetus
for Flipt. I know that was a very
rambling
answer.
But, basically, I thought, you know, why don't
we build a feature flag solution that is
meant for engineers that they can just kind
of get up and running and works in
their stack
so they don't have to maintain it themselves.
Nice. Awesome.
That's a pretty comprehensive overview of of why
you've done this. So let's let's come at
it from a different angle. Right? Like,
I think we understand the importance of future
flags. We understand some of the challenges. Definitely
understand why people should be building their own
solution for this. Right? It's it's one of
these problems domains. It seems from a naive
set of eyes really simple. But actually, once
you start building out a real production like
feature flagging system, I imagine those complexities really
start to surface themselves.
And I'm sure we're gonna get into that
as we talk about what Flipt is and
how it delivers and all that stuff. But
let's again come at it from another angle.
I'm gonna try not to just ramble at,
you know. But you've
decided to write. I've seen this in GitHub.
We wanna solve this problem.
You must have looked to see if there
were other open source projects out there. What
was the
the point, the inflection point where you're you
know what? These don't do what I wanted
to do, and we need to build something
else. Like, what was happening at the time,
and what did you think could be different
with a potential solution?
Yep.
Yeah. I mean, I guess back you know,
this was several years ago. I was a
bit naive myself, and, you know, I briefly
looked at,
what other solutions were out there.
And at the time, the big player and
still is, I think, launched Rawkode. Right? And
so that is what everyone knows or everyone
thinks of when you say feature flag solution.
Yeah. They have all the big bucks, the
big marketing dollars.
And,
you know, to me, a SaaS tool,
or a SaaS feature flag solution never didn't
make a lot of sense for what I
thought feature flags were used for and should
be used for.
And that's mainly because of the latency that's
involved from, you know, making requests from your
applications to this this external SaaS that you
don't control.
And, you know, especially when you think about
where feature flags are
embedded in your code base, they're usually in
hot paths, like request paths.
And so any downtime in the your feature
flag solution means that your code then,
you know, fails.
And so to me, a SaaS was not
was a nonstarter. Right? And so and GitHub
felt the same way. That's why they didn't
use a a SaaS tool.
And so I looked at, okay, what self
hosted feature flag solutions are out there? And
I believe at the time, there was Unleash.
I'm try this was a few years ago.
And, hopefully, I'm it's cool to just name
drop these things. Yeah. No. Of course. Okay.
I don't wanna yeah. So, you know, there
was Unleash,
and, you know, I think
there are there are obviously others now. A
lot of them to me,
look like they are
more focused on product,
managers to try to do things like AB
test, try to see which version of the
dashboard converts better and all that stuff.
To me, they they didn't seem like they
were meant for engineering teams that were,
you know,
are interested in hooking up their, you know,
telemetry tools or their observability observability
tools,
things like that.
And, also,
I noticed they were all implemented using REST.
And I think, you know, obviously, REST is
a great technology.
Everyone uses is familiar with REST APIs.
But at the time, gRPC was relatively new
and or at least new to me. And
I thought, you know, this seems like a
perfect use case for gRPC where it's, like,
you know, meant to be low latency.
It's meant to run, you know, for in
your application in your data center,
to do server to server communication.
So I said, okay. There's no there didn't
seem to be a feature flag solution implemented
with gRPC. Let me see if I can
build one.
And you're seeing all the right things.
So that developer focus, open source feature flag
and library that runs over issue to p
two gRPC.
I mean, that's got performance characteristics over it
that I I like and have struggled with
in the past with feature flagging. Especially the
SAS angle, I've never understood why people are
willing to accept that. We're in trip time
to just query a flag and, of course,
they batch them now at the start of
the application, all this other stuff. But
obviously in the wild for me and maybe
not as wild as the lunch darkly pricing,
but I don't wanna get into that. So
Yep. Yeah.
Alright. That's awesome. So why don't you give
me
a I'll throw this one to you, George.
I've not heard your voice in a way.
I'm starting to miss it. Yeah. What's
what's the the tech stack? We've heard GRPC.
Tell me a little bit more about what
Flipt is built upon.
Totally.
Yes. Obviously, gRPC,
Flipt is written in Go primarily, although we
also,
embed a a front end application, which is
written in TypeScript and React.
Previously, we were using
just JavaScript
and Vue, if I remember early, but we
recently like, in the last year, we sort
of switched to TypeScript and React.
And then Flipt is really quite extensible in
terms of
what you can
run Flipt in front of,
and we we support a range of of
back ends.
So, historically,
Flipt from day one has supported, like, relational
database back ends. So
SQLite,
Postgres, MySQL,
and then eventually we had CockroachDB
as well. I think now we we support
Terso as
well. So
we have those back ends. And then also
more recently, we've been working on some slightly
different back ends to support more, like, GitOps
friendly workflows.
So we support going
direct to your local file system to some
just to a set of files. We go
direct to git. You can go to object
storage like AWS
s three or
very recently, literally Wednesday,
we added support for for OCI registries
as a source of truth.
So you can plug this into a number
of these these back ends that can be
that can be your source of truth.
And then we also have a a bunch
of sort of, like, ancillary technologies that we
we connect into.
So we
we're fully instrumented with OpenTelemetry.
I think we also have a native one
straight to Jaeger if you don't wanna use
OpenTelemetry.
I forget what else. I think maybe that
is all the pieces of the puzzle. There
are lots of pieces you can pick and
choose.
Again, you're you're you're saying all the right
things. Right? I hear tracing and OpenTelemetry.
I hear Go. I mean, I'd love to
hear some rest, but, know, I'll take I'll
still take go. I still love go. Yeah.
Yeah. You know, TypeScript is always I know
we should do in front ends. I think
TypeScript is a phenomenal language. You know, this
is a modern tech stack for a modern
open source library and that's, you know, great.
The only thing I'd love to see you
just throw it in for the next really
damn hell of it would be about WebAssembly,
but maybe that's for a future stream. We
we we we have played. Yeah.
Played
with Rust. We're playing with Rust.
We have a Rust client.
We
Mark's been playing with a client side evaluator
in Rust. That's sweet. We've
played with WASM on a different sort of
project on the side, but we're thinking, no.
If it's new and shiny, we we love
it, I think.
Always experiment. Awesome.
Well, thank you both for sharing all of
that. I think we should get a screen
shared and maybe try and show people how
they can get started with Flipt. Unless there's
anything you want to cover before we get
onto the hands on component of this.
No. I don't think so. I have a
little bit of a demo prepared if if
you want me share.
Okay. Please. Yeah. Throw it up. Let's
Do you
hopefully, it doesn't make me restart
because we're
using a new tool. Let's see. Yeah. Oh,
got it.
Sorry. I'm just gonna enter my New search.
Password.
Oh, it's gonna make me quit.
So is it you could just say later,
and normally, it still works. Nice.
Hacks.
Okay. Alright. Let's share
screen.
Now it says Google Chrome has lost permissions
to share screen.
Oh, you can restart and jump back in
there. I'll Okay. I'll tell the joke to
George.
No, George. You tell the joke. Cool.
I don't have any jokes to that. You
got my dad?
I actually I came up with some like,
I spent
half an hour, maybe not even as much
as that, at Halloween googling jokes from my
five year old daughter to tell her she
was going to her dream.
And they were all absolutely terrible, but the
best part of it was is that she
started trying to make up her own jokes,
but she doesn't really understand why the jokes
are funny.
But she I mean, she laughs at any
joke I tell her. But then she tries
to tell a joke and she says something
like, why did the chicken cross the road
to get his dinner? And you're like,
yeah. I don't think you quite understand the
structure of the joke. Yeah.
And Rawk's just like, what the fuck? That
was a good joke.
God. Alright. It's still saying I can't share.
Let me try one more time.
Yeah. Sorry. No rush. Take your time.
Screen recording.
Because I don't normally use Google Chrome, maybe
that's why.
I'm not typing. Tell me a dinosaur joke
for a five year old and to chat
GPT.
Why did the dinosaur bring a ladder to
the party?
I don't know why.
Because it heard the drinks were on the
roof.
That's
terrible.
Wait.
What?
Alright. Tell me a Linux container joke.
Why did the Linux container go to therapy?
Don't know why. Because it had a severe
case of separation anxiety. Man, Chad GPT should
not give up his day job.
He should not.
Hey. I see a screen. There we go.
Alright.
Sweet.
Let me close that.
Yep.
Alright. Can you all see?
We can. I'm gonna do the obligatory.
You're gonna have to triple tap zoom on
a couple of these things, but other than
that,
Let me increase the
is that any better? I'd go one more
on each.
I know it feels so big on your
side, but the audience will thank you.
Yeah. Let me my mouse went away now.
So that's fun.
Okay.
I cannot find a mouse.
What is happening?
Didn't
practically demo gods.
Yeah.
If you wiggle it fast enough, did Mac
not make it jump out of the screen?
Big old big old mouse. I really don't
know where it went. I'm gonna hook up
a USB mouse. This
is wild.
Cool.
I'm in the room.
An old channel says, thanks for putting this
together. We need more get ups. Yeah. We
always need more get ups.
Nice.
I always feel that with the we've worked
folks, mister Trick,
by calling it get ops and not commit
ops. Like, they've tied it Mhmm. Rate to
one thing. And I think commit ops just
turns a bit nicer.
Alright. I'm ready now. I don't know if
can you still see my screen? No. It's
been unshared.
Okay.
It's probably for the best.
Alright.
Thanks for coming. We'll see you later.
Alright. Alright.
Good. Good. Cool. Found my mouse. Everything's good.
Alright. So we, so this is our documentation.
Right? You just go to Flipt.i0/docs,
and it puts you in this getting started
page.
And the demo that I'm gonna do is
based off of what we call, Flipt Labs,
and it's this little repository put together to
kinda demonstrate,
like, what you can do with Flipt. Because
one of the challenging things that we found
when,
you know, trying to show this tool off
is that it requires integration with an application
to really be useful. Right? Like, it's not
really useful in itself. Like, I mean, you
can run it via, you know, very simply
very easily via Docker,
but then you load the dashboard and it's
like, okay. I can create some flags and
create some segments, but what do I do
with that? And so to kinda solve that
problem,
we
created this
re this repo called Fliptlabs.
And so we created a couple, like, demo
applications,
to to show it off. And so the
one I'm gonna demo demonstrate is called chatbot.
And so let's see. So I have it
running locally,
and it's basically
a
kind of a live
tutorial,
that you can kind of,
run through,
you know, on your on your own. And
so we have, like, three different sections of
it. We have, like, a basic, advanced,
and a GitOps.
I'm gonna fast forward through the git to
the GitOps because I think that's probably more
interesting to people.
The basic is just kinda like what are
flags, why would you use them, that kind
of thing.
And so
this
this example is basically gonna show you how
you could roll out a a chatbot for
your application,
to a subset of users, and so you
can kind of test it in production. And
then it's gonna show you how you can
change the runtime behavior of that chatbot
using feature flags without having to do a
code redeploy.
And it's gonna do all that with,
serving a feature flag data from Git. And
so that's kind of the GitOps aspect of
it.
I guess, any
any, questions or anything before I start? Or
Nope? Nope. Cool. Please hang on. Alright. David's
saying something, but I can't hear you, David.
Can you hear me, Mark? Yeah. I can
hear you now. Yep.
Alright.
I'm gonna see I don't I don't really
have any questions. Right? There was something really
cool that you said at the start. I
wanna kinda emphasize instead of a frame, right,
for people who are gonna see this demo.
And you said that, you know, feature flags
allow us I can't remember your exact phrase.
Right? But to make two things distinct, deployment
and feature delivery. Really? Exactly.
And, you know, feature flags are such a
great way of you know, especially as people
are doing proper continuous integration and we are
account based development, any of these things where
they're constantly working on new things, they're always
in production, and feature flags allow you to
toggle them on, off, release them to subsets,
do alpha beta testing, a b 10, all
this other stuff.
Really, it reduces a lot of the anxiety
and fear that people have from continuous deployment
or deployment pipelines.
So, you know, keep that in mind as
you look at this demo and then you
go into it and just understand how much
flexibility,
stability, and performance power, all of that stuff
you can get. So no pressure, but you're
live up to all of that now. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. One, I guess in that in
that vein, one quote I came across recently
from, Rich Hickey,
the founder of Closure, I believe,
said all bugs in production,
pass testing,
which I thought was interesting because it's like,
you can't, you know, you can't test everything.
Right? So, like, testing in production
is, in my opinion, you know, one of
the best ways to
to handle,
things that you can't catch in test.
So yeah.
Anyways, let's,
let's get going. So
we this all runs, with Docker Compose.
And so I have the repository checked out
locally. I'm in the chatbot folder. Here, let
me increase the
font a little bit. And so it just,
it's gonna kind of give you an overview
of what's gonna happen,
but I'm just gonna copy and paste these
commands.
And,
hopefully, this should all work. I tested it
yesterday.
So, basically, what this is doing
yeah. What this is doing is spinning up
an instance of Flipt in
a Docker container, and it's also spinning up
an instance of git GITI GITIIA. I'm not
really sure how to pronounce it. Probably gitea,
which is an open source,
you know, git, like, GitHub kinda clone.
And so
that's gonna allow us to demonstrate the the
GitOps part of it.
And so what we're gonna do okay. It
looks like everything's running.
So we're gonna go to
yep. Alright. So this is,
it's going to ask us to log in.
I probably should've opened that in a different
tab.
Yep. So we're gonna log in with username
Flipt,
password, password.
And so let me also just kinda demonstrate
Flipt while we're here.
So this is the the Flipt dashboard,
once you, you know, once you get it
up and running. And so here, you can
see we have a flag called chat enabled,
and this is the flag that is going
to guard our chatbot
that's gonna show up in this tutorial.
Spoiler.
And so right now, it's disabled.
And one thing you can see is that
Flipt is running in read only mode,
and that's because it's backed by our our
GitOps back end, backed by Git storage.
And so, normally, if you're not running in
in one of these declarative with one these
declarative back ends,
you know, you can it's a basic CRUD,
you know, web app. Right? You can click
on things, create things, all that stuff. But
because
we're now serving your feature flag data from
Git,
you know, obviously, you can't
there would be a a mismatch
if you were able to create things in
UI
and also create things in Git. I mean,
that's something we eventually wanna solve is to
allow you to, you know, use the UI,
and then that gets
still gets persisted to whatever back end you're
using.
But right now, if you're using one of
our declarative back ends, it puts flipped in
this read only mode.
And so, yeah, you can see that the
flag is disabled right now.
But we're gonna change that by
taking a look at so here's the the
YAML file,
the declarative format that Flipt is is reading
from,
which defines that flag and defines its state.
And so right now, it matches what you
see in the UI.
And so we're gonna go continue with the
tutorial here.
And
yep. So, basically, it's saying, okay. You know,
you're at the point where you wanna enable
this chatbot,
and here's how you would do that. So,
you know, everything I just said, it's in
the disabled state. Says, luckily, one of our
colleagues has already prepared a PR to enable
this flag.
So we're gonna go here and
uh-oh.
Colleague has not prepared the PR.
Let me re
let me restart this.
Nothing like a live demo.
Sometimes this,
demo doesn't work,
every time, so you have to recreate it.
I blame George.
Yeah. It's definitely my fault.
Yeah.
There we go. Alright. So,
now we can see that our
helpful,
colleague has prepared a PR to change,
the feature flag from false to true,
and so we're gonna merge that.
Oh, it's gonna make me sign in again.
Alright.
Okay. So merged.
And now
hey. Now our little chatbot shows up,
almost instantly. Because what's happening in the background
is Flipt is polling that GitHub repository,
watching for changes,
and it saw that, okay, the flag went
from enabled false to true. And so now
your application can query that flag and get
the value of true.
And so here's our little chatbot
that that showed up.
And so
this this doesn't really matter for the demo,
but this chatbot is actually,
trained on our, on our own docs.
We actually went and embedded our documentation in
a into a vector database and doing all
that OpenAI,
business.
So you can actually ask this chatbot questions
about Flipt itself.
And you say, like
and,
yeah, we can give you a somewhat helpful
answer,
of where Flipt runs.
And so, yeah, I guess I'll pause here
for any any questions,
before I before I go on or any
anything you wanna talk about.
I can't hear
David, I think you're muted. Or
Can somewhat hear you.
Oh, okay.
You hear me there?
Yeah.
Yeah. I I don't know what happened there,
but the Mac changed for them to be
iPhone.
Oh.
And
I don't know why, which explains why I
was saying the best jokes in the world
just like five minutes. Nobody
was laughing.
That's
Anyway,
I I said blame George, and then you
said blame George. And I was like, hold
on a minute. I just missed it. My
joke.
No. That's usually cool. Keep going. I do
have questions, but I think, you know, I
I wanna see the the DX of this,
the clip perspective, but let's keep going just
just now, and then I'll come back to
that.
Okay. Cool. So, yeah, so I just refreshed
Flipt, and you can see that it's enabled
here as well.
And so
let's continue on.
Okay. Already did that. Already did that. Okay.
And so,
basically, what I just showed is, like, how
most people, I think, think of feature flags,
kind of that boolean state, like, on or
off, either features enabled or disabled.
And so another
another cool thing you can do with Flipt
and most other feature flag tools is they
have the idea of variance.
And so it's not just a typical on
off, but you can also return other values.
And you can say, okay. I want these
to be distributed at different,
percentages.
So you could say, you know, I want
5050%
of my users to get the value blue,
another 50% to get red, and you can
change that over time, right, without redeploying your
app.
And so we're we're kind of trying to
demonstrate that here,
where where we added another feature flag called
chat personas.
And so what we wanna do what we
wanna demonstrate
is, you know, we're testing like, put your
mind,
put yourself in the shoes of an engineer
who's trying to deploy this chatbot for real,
and maybe they wanna test out different personas
of that chatbot. So, like, the default
is, like, friendly.
Maybe they, you know, they're feeling sassy, and
the they wanna test out a sarcastic
chatbot.
And then, you know, just for kicks, they
wanna test out one who who tells you,
like,
BS. Right? Who's a who's a liar. And
so
we we try to demonstrate that with another
pull request here
where we How annoying would it be for
me to ask that we change one of
the personas just for laughs?
Can we have an Ace Ventura persona?
We can we can try. Yeah.
Let me let me merge this
Yeah. I'll let you know and then we
can matters in the works. Right.
Actually, because yeah. Because because in in the
next step, we're actually gonna modify this file
and push it up. And so, yeah, we
we can we'll get there.
So let me go ahead and merge that.
Alright.
And so
let's see what happened in Flipt. So now
there's two flags. Right? There's chat enabled and
chat personas,
and you can see it created those variants
that I was talking about. And then we
have the rules defined which say,
okay. Which percentage of requests are gonna get
which, variant? And so they're all set at
a third right now, right, where default's,
slightly,
favored.
And so
continuing
with the tutorial oh, it would scroll up
to the top.
So
enable
sorry. In order to kind of test this,
we need we need something that is distinct.
So in this example, we're choosing, a username.
Right? But it could be anything like an
IP address or, you know, user ID or
whatever. But we need something
to determine,
okay, the stickiness.
So we always wanna make sure that the
same user gets the same variant of chatbot
because it would be weird if, like, you
know, all of a sudden you're talk you
know, you're talking to a friendly chatbot, then
all of a sudden he starts to get
all, like, sassy. Right?
And so
the the way we're demonstrating that is via
this username
field.
And so I'll just say my username is
David,
and then I'm gonna ask the chatbot questions
like
yeah. So
first, you got the the liar chatbot,
but, actually, he is telling the truth here,
so,
ignore that.
But
let's try let's try George and see which
version George gets.
And so flip sorry. George got the sarcastic
one.
So what database is done with support?
So you're pretty much covered.
And so we're just trying to show, like,
you know, that you can different users will
get different variants, but George will always get
the sarcastic one. David will always get the
liar one who's not necessarily lying.
And so the way that you're controlling that
is via PRs,
and contributions
via Git.
And so I think what might really bring
it home is if we can show, like,
okay. As a engineer, as a developer, how
would you actually make a change
to you know, if you didn't have a
PR prepared?
So let's do that
here.
And then we're going to clone
it.
And so now we're actually gonna change that,
that percentage.
So say we wanna say, okay. We want
everyone to get the sarcastic,
chatbot.
Actually, you've been done and not again because
all my key findings are off.
So, basically, what I'm doing here is I'm
setting all the other variations to zero and
the sarcastic one to 100%.
And I'm gonna close it, and I'm gonna
commit it and push it up.
Are you running fake in your terminal?
Yes.
I was late seeing other people's terminal set.
They sound quite chunky. Oh,
yeah.
Trying to remember which keyboard. I got it
from WASD
keyboards.
It's like Cherry MX clears.
Nice.
Yeah. I do like I don't know if
it's WASD or WASD or whatever you're supposed
to pronounce, but I do like their keyboards.
Yeah. Yeah. I had a code keyboard from
forget who. Maybe it's them. I really like
that one. But That's not what it's actually
was at, but it was the Stack Overflow
team that Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's come
back a while ago. Like, what, 2010,
I think, when they first came out.
Yeah. That explains why why it was crusty,
and I had to get a new one.
Yeah. It's a
pretty old one. They still sell them. I
think they sell really well. So
Nice.
So, basically, yeah, what I did is I
just kinda YOLO'd this commit and pushed it
to main.
And now, hopefully, everybody should be getting the
the sarcastic chatbot regardless of who they are.
And,
yeah, this is just me testing the same
thing. But, anyways, we can go back to
Flipt and see that now
that variant is at a %
without you making any changes in the UI.
Cool. And that's, I guess, really ultimately what
we're trying to demonstrate there.
Alright.
Can
we've just seen the house to kind of
configure the flags
with Flipt.
What does it look like from the SDK
point of view? Like, how do I put
this into my
code?
Yeah.
George, do wanna take that one?
Do you want to see an actual,
like, example in code? I can share my
screen. Would that be helpful? Or Well, yeah.
I'm assuming this website
uses some sort of SDK to request the
chatbot persona.
So, you know, if we could just take
a look at that code and see, you
know, like, I want developers to be able
to understand. Okay. I can create a flag,
push them to get all those reloading
for me, but at runtime, at code time,
how do I get this value?
Yeah. I can I can show that real
quick? Just for this example labs
demo, if that's what
Let's see. So
yeah. So I guess a broader answer to
your question is kind of what SDKs do
we support, and then I can talk about,
like, which one the demo's using.
And so as I as I alluded to
earlier,
Flipt supports both REST and gRPC,
and so we have a combination of both
SDKs. We have our REST SDKs
available in, like, five or six different languages,
you know, Node, TypeScript, Python, Go, Rust, Java.
We just added a PHP
rest SDK because of a amazing contributor contributed
that.
And so that's currently in beta.
And then as far as gRPC,
obviously, with gRPC,
you can anybody can generate their own SDK
setup or any anyone can generate their own
clients. That's one of the beauties of gRPC.
But we have a couple that we already
went ahead and generated for you and published
just to kind of remove that extra step.
And so we have them for Go,
Ruby, and.net, and we're currently working on publishing
a Java one.
And then finally, we have
we are supporting this project
called Open Feature, which I don't know if
you've heard about, but it's kind of like
the open telemetry for feature flags where they
got a bunch of feature flag vendors together
and said, you know, let's come up with
a common interface,
a common API that we can all,
you know, conform to to enable
our to enable end users to basically have
one one SDK,
but then be able to switch out feature
flag providers. So it doesn't matter if you're
using LaunchDarkly or Unleash or Flipt. You don't
have to change your s your your code.
You can just
swap out a different provider.
And so,
it's actually a CNCF,
project,
and, you know, we have two different providers
right now,
Go and Java, and then we're we have
the PHP one on the way.
And so I guess
I can I can continue with the the
chat
chatbot example and show the actual SDK code
there Yeah? If you want. Or okay.
And another thing to mention, sorry, before I
get to that, is we also publish our
open API
definition.
And so you can generate your own REST
clients as well if you want,
but they're not as,
you know they're they're kinda hit or miss
on which ones are idiomatic.
We have we have a Rust SDK. We
have we have a Rust
Rust SDK.
Yep. Yeah. There you go. Alright.
So
let's go
let me just show you real quick what
the
chatbot
is
using
think it's here.
Yep.
Me just search. Sorry. I wasn't.
No more code search.
I know that.
Sorry. I should have been more prepared.
Is it here? Here it is. Alright. Sorry.
So,
here, we're importing our node,
SDK,
and it's called Flipt API client. And,
basically, you give it the environment or the
URL that Flipt is available at.
In this case, it's just local host. And
then we're just, using a use effects,
React hook to basically do
check this flag.
Default here is the namespace,
and I'll I can talk about that in
a second.
But the the flag is called chat enabled,
and so it's just, you know, whenever you
refresh the page, basically, saying,
okay.
Check and see if this
this
actually, sorry. Not when you refresh the page.
Just checking every five seconds.
If it's checking to see if this flag
is enabled.
And so that's that's pretty much it. It's
just a single line to to get the
flag here. Yeah. Nice and easy. Cool. Yep.
I think as well in this project, we've
got
the
correct me if I'm wrong with me. The
the part that has the LLM is in
Python, and do we that is a Flipt
client. So we have a Python SDK
in here too
being demonstrated.
Yes. Good point.
Right. I yeah. So I just showed the
the front end flag,
and then we have on the back end,
as George just said, we have a Python
REST SDK as well.
And so that one is doing all the
the variant checking to determine which persona the
chatbot should
should should respond with.
And so
let's get down here.
Yeah. So
Flipt can be used
from a consumer point of view in a
handful of ways.
I would say most probably 99%
of people use our evaluate API,
and that's what this
SDK is using here. And so that's taking
that context,
which in the lab example was the the
username,
and it's sending it to Flipt, and it's
saying, okay. Give me what I should what
variant I should use
return to this user. And so that's this
evaluate call here.
And so here you can see it's building
up that evaluation request,
and,
we use we use a, number called entity
ID because we didn't want to
kind of force you
to you to think about feature flags as
only a user facing thing.
And so, you know, a lot of, feature
flag tools use the the nomenclature
of user ID. Well, I mean, you can
use feature flag for pretty much anything like,
you know, rate limits or, you know, log
levels or, you know, things that aren't aren't
necessarily
driven
by a user's action. And so that's why
we just call it into the ID.
But, anyways, that's the that's the username here.
It does a call to evaluate, and it
returns the variant.
And here, you can see we're actually using,
another
field from the variant, which is an attachment,
and that just allows you to to put
arbitrary JSON
in the variant response.
And that's where we're actually getting the prompt
from is that that JSON response.
So you can actually change the
well, if it wasn't in re only mode,
you could actually change the
the
prompt within Flipt without having to redeploy your
application,
which would then change the behavior that the
that OpenAI is
getting. Nice. So
yeah.
Alright. Anything else to demo, or what goes
back into Big Facebook?
I don't know. George, did you wanna demo
the
OCI or do I don't know. I
mean, I could do I could do a
quick
run through of
sort of running Flipt with, an OCI registry
instead. That's
Happy to see it. Yeah. Let's do it.
See it. Let's do it. Alright. Bear with
me. Make sure I'm on the right
screen.
Okay. Let me share my screen.
Yeah. So as we said,
it's gonna make me I'm gonna have to
go through that same dance sign that Mark
did, obviously.
Bear with me.
I'll get the joke. So
I'll be right back.
I've asked OpenAI to tell me a joke
about feature flags for a five year old.
Are you strapped in? Ready?
Yeah. Why
why did the computer go to the circus?
Because it wanted to see amazing feature flags
perform their magical trick.
No. That's
I don't I don't get it. Open AI.
I'm sorry.
Yeah. I I don't think it under undersized
jokes. Yeah.
Much like my five year old daughter.
Can
you can you hear me? Yes. We can.
I see. I can't hear David now. Sounds
weird. But I can see that you can
hear David. This is very confusing.
How can it's wild.
Do you want me to translate? Or
Yeah. You relay.
Oh, yeah. Relay. There you go. That's it.
Can you see my screen? I can't see
anyone. Yes. So
let me move it a bit smaller. Then
maybe I can see other people. I know
because then I get the horrible Yeah. Like,
horrible windows.
Can you, yeah, increase it?
Let's go big.
Yeah. That's good.
And then let me go
I'm gonna create my own
directory just to demonstrate this. So, yeah,
as I said, we recently added an OCI
back end
for Flipt.
The purpose here was
so as we said before, our Git back
end, it
will sync your source repository in order to,
like, materialize
its state.
And that's great, especially for, like, getting Flipt
up and running,
really quick because all you need is a
GitHub repo and Flipt as a container, and
then you're, like you've got everything you need,
with the clients to sort of build your
end to end setup.
But, like, where that might eventually,
like,
you know, have some issues with scale is
if you're constantly cloning your repository and say
you want to have your feature flags defined
in line with your code in a site
like a Monoreto repo setup.
Obviously,
Flipt's performance
starts to do a grade
with the sort of scale of the repository
there or something. So if that repository gets
really big, then it takes a little bit
longer for Flipt's to have to, like,
start up and clone initially.
And then if you've also got, like, a
large
sort of flow of contributions into that Git
repo,
then
then all of that becomes work that has
to go through to keep in sync that
might not be relevant.
And also maybe from, like, a security perspective,
maybe you don't wanna give Flipt an entire
repository
and all of its contents. Maybe you're really
interested in just giving it, like, what it
cares about, which is, flag state. Can you
hear me yet, George? So OCI kind of
presents a nice
way to sort of solve your own problems.
And
it obviously requires an extra component. You need,
like, an OCI registry.
But once you add that,
Flipt comes with all the pieces you need
to, like
you'd leverage that registry.
And now that registries are so
prevalent and so available,
especially for folks that are already, you in
containerized environments, they've got you've usually got access
to one.
It's probably not
a big ask to to then start leveraging
it for
for your feature flag state as well. And
so as I said, we've we've added
some extra commands
to the Flipt binary. So this is the
same binary that is the server
for Flipt, and
these commands are all nestled under a sort
of sub command called bundle.
And
this
allows you to turn a directory full of
feature flag state into
it's like an OCI bundle that you can
push to
to some registry and then run Fliptover.
So I'll just quickly create one of those
files you've already seen, like a features dot
YAML file.
I'm just gonna make a flag called, like,
awesome feature.
Probably doesn't matter. I'll
turn it off for now.
And I'm gonna, like, turn that into
into a bundle. So let me just build
that. I'm just gonna call it my bundle.
Gonna give it a tag.
So there is a command to, like, look
at all your bundles. This just builds a
bundle that's local to your machine. You can
actually run Flipt over local bundles, the two,
if you want to,
rather than having to go through a registry,
but I think that doesn't really explain anything.
You can see a bunch of other bundles
I've built. This is very sort of familiar
if you're, you know, if you're used using
a tool like Docker
and Docker build and things like that.
Okay.
So I'm gonna now push that to a
registry,
and
and then I'm gonna run Flipt and use
that to sort of source it.
So
I'm gonna use if anyone's familiar with TTL,
which is like a femoral
ephemeral
registry,
I'm gonna use that to sort of host
it nice and quickly.
TTL.
Shir asks
that you give them a random
UUID
to to push to push to.
So I'm gonna push
that bundle
and
just give it the UUID, and you can
give it a time limit, sort of self
destructing
self destructing bundle.
So the next ten minutes will be available
once once I get it there.
It's taking a while.
It's a lot quicker normally. Promise. And now
I'm gonna I'm
gonna run Flipt. So I'm just gonna quickly
run it locally.
You just need to tell Flipt that we're
gonna use the
OCI back end,
and then we need to tell it, like,
what repository
we want to follow. So I'm gonna tell
it to follow this, like, ten minute
repo.
I tell you what it is. I've just
got too many
instances of flips running.
I've made that mistake before.
Okay. Wow. That was bold on the street.
And if
I
You still got here. Think I said go.
Yeah. You come back over here. You go
up to Chrome. Sorry for the infinite
infinite window.
Cool. So we can see that we can
see that flag.
We could Let me zoom in a little
bit. Zoom in here.
So we're back here in there. Let me
change my name. Maybe it'll help him here,
mate. We could re we could,
you know, we could update this bundle.
Let's do that. So they have feature flag.
Can you hear me, George?
Let's let's
build the bundle.
Maybe I should restart Chrome.
And Flipt is
configured at the moment with a thirty second
polling interval,
so it might take
a minute. You know? Well, not a minute,
but half half a minute to to see
that update, but
you can obviously bring that that polled interval
down for
eventually,
see this come through.
That's there. So yes. So now you've got,
like,
the CLI
for building bundles and distributing them.
We think that, yeah, this might help with
scaling out the GitOps
sort of workflow for flags.
Alright. And also you Or do have questions
when he's ready? We intend to use the
leverage tags for doing things like
pushing sort of different versions of flags for
different environments. So you might use tags for,
like, you know, long lived staging environments, or
you might tag them with the commit that
they're built from and use that for preview
environments or the branch that you're building on.
So, yeah, lots of Good George. There.
Yeah.
David says you look great, and he
has questions
when we
Amazing. Yes. Alright. So that I don't have
to translate everything I say through you, Mark.
If you could ask George maybe just to
leave and come back and see if it
helps before we meet with this awkward trip.
Yeah. The first question he has is can
can you leave and come and see
if that will fix this audio issue? Let's
do that.
Be right back.
K.
But I have no problem written on my
questions through you, but, you know, it's kind
of fun.
Fun social experiment.
Yeah.
It's like a, you know,
George's partner will broke it up and I'm
like, can you please tell George? I
won't be home for dinner. Come get us
stuck.
Hello?
George?
No.
Maybe he muted you. Is that a thing?
Yeah. Did you mute me, George?
Did I a way to mute?
Alright. Let's try this.
It's very strange there.
Can you hear me?
And you nope. Nothing?
Alright. We'll do this the awkward way, but
we are near the end so it doesn't
really matter.
Okay. Yeah. I have I have I have
no idea
why you can't hear me, George. So really
sorry about that.
But this is really cool. There's a few
things that I think are really important about
supporting OCI in this way.
One,
I really like mono repositories.
I can't remember if we've had this conversation
or not in the past.
I'm gonna give you a huge monologue here,
Mark, and I I wanna hear more. Mark's
still in the word.
Okay. Real quick. David David really likes monorepository.
Amazing.
Yeah.
And what
are the challenges of a monorepository?
And this comes down to building container artifacts
and and trying to do get ups, but
also the same for feature flags with get
ups. Is that I want my feature flags
to live next to the code or at
least in some representation of somebody that was
to ship the way so the developers can
understand what's happening. Right?
When we support OCI, we can actually say
it's through CICD
process. We can build an artifact,
a snapshot of time, and push it somewhere
that could easily be consumed. And we'll get
our commits aren't technically the sort of truth.
I mean, they are. We we just have,
like, a materialized view that we put into
OCI. I think that's a really powerful model.
So that's sweet.
You said
so it's all good.
I really enjoyed watching this back later. I
get, like, all the context.
Yeah. George, you could just watch it back
later. Right? Mark, you could answer my questions
from now on. I don't wanna speak to
George. So
what I'm curious about now is, like, say
I go all in on this. I wanna
use Flipt. I wanna use GRPC. I want
feature flags. I want OCI.
The these are things that or generally, these
are things I wanna use yesterday.
So one of the things that George did
is he's ran Flipt with the feature back
end store. I can't remember the flag. Right?
But he pointed it to an OCI
artifact including
the the tag.
Can I follow as version tag or prefix
of tags? Like, how do I get updates
to that? And
without overriding the tag, can I? Or do
I just need to accept that I have
an ephemeral tag?
Today,
you cannot.
It's basically the tags are meant to be,
like like you said, the source of truth.
Right? And you would have to update the
configuration file,
to say, wanna follow a different tag. Prefix
tags is a good idea that we haven't
thought about.
I mean, obviously, if you use something like
latest, which is, you know, bad practice,
but if you keep pushing the latest, it
Flipt will continuously pull and pull down any
changes.
But if you're using something like a git
shot to to tag your image, then you're
just gonna have to update it each time.
Yeah. A a pattern we see in Kubernetes
seems to be
to use semantic versions
on the tagging. Mhmm. And then the get
ops controller will resolve that to a SHA
over every every interval. And so you're then
you're still deploying to one specific digest, which
is great.
But we can opt them to updates on
a minor or a patch release, but not
on a major release and stuff. I think
that kind of semantic some resolver
Yeah. That would be a really cool iteration.
And it's open source. Right? So if I
wanna see this, I could just go in
and hack on some code. Yeah.
Anyway yeah. Really, really cool. So that's a
great demo from both of you.
I'm gonna
just because things are now awkward and George
is the is their part.
And I'll just kick it out. It's fine.
The best, to be honest.
I'll just do a quick recap then. You
know, Flipt is a a pretty sweet piece
of software. It's open source. It's ready to
go. It's GRPC. It could be performing.
It provides a strong developer first experience for
doing feature flagging
as a single binary that could be deployed
very easily locally using Terzil was the one
that stood out to me. Like, I think
Terzil is such a great product. So, you
know, do using something like that seems like
a great idea to me and
even OCI as well. So lots of different
opportunities there for me to run this in
production and be happy and a pretty nice
SDK front end where I can use generated
GRPC's in pretty much any language. Right? Because
it's so ubiquitous now.
But also a handful of rest full rest
like I don't even know what the correct
terminology is anymore. APIs for people that wanna
go on more traditional route. I mean, throwing
some GraphQL, you've got everything covered there. Right?
But
pretty sweet.
Mean We're not GraphQL fans.
Oh,
that's alright.
Any last words that you want to share
and and then
maybe share a bit more about the the
road map. Right? We've we've got a snapshot
now, a good understanding of what Flipt does,
the problem it solves, where it is today.
Why don't you tell me a little bit
more about tomorrow? And feel free to share
any of it links or
prior profiles. Shameless plug anything that you want.
Yep. Yep. Great.
So I don't know if I can actually
type in chat here, but
our website is Flipt.io.
Our repository is Flipt-i0
on GitHub.
As David said, there's a number of ways
you can deploy and run Flipt yourself. We
support, you know, Docker containers, obviously. We have
a Helm chart.
So we're I would say we were cloud
adjacent.
We're not not cloud native maybe, but we
can run pretty much on any infrastructure because
it's where you can go, and we have
binaries for almost every architecture that you can
think of.
As far as the road map,
so today, Flipt does all of its evaluation
server side,
which is, you know, probably the most common
pattern that I think most feature flag tools,
kind of, use.
But that again, it's it's not great for
everybody.
So, like, the mobile use case, for example,
if you have, you know, a mobile app
that, you know, the the user might not
have great network connectivity,
you don't want everything
every time the user does something, your mobile
app to have to reach out over the
network and evaluate a feature flag.
So we're actually working on client side evaluation
as well, client side SDKs,
and so that's where the Rust comes in.
We are we basically rewrote our evaluation logic
in Rust,
and then we're using FFI,
which is foreign function interface,
I think. So
we're creating a a dynamic library that actually
does evaluation.
And then the client side SDKs,
written in Go, TypeScript, Ruby, you know, what
have you, will basically use FFI
to say, okay. I have this context.
Now do the evaluation Rust library, and then
it will will return a response.
And so we actually created a new set
of gRPC,
or an internal API
to
take all of the flag state
that and then the Rust library can
query that that endpoint,
get the data that it needs to then
perform the evaluation client side.
And as you can imagine, it's extremely fast,
you know, client side. And so we're actually
working on that right now. We hope to
have that open source in the next couple
of weeks.
We're just kinda running into some issues with,
like, how to package
those
SDKs in the native languages because not all
of them allow you to easily
link
library written in Rust and then push up
to the package registry. But,
anyway, so if you have any interest in
Rust or FFI or,
you know, integrating
with other languages,
please drop by our Discord or GitHub repository.
Yeah.
Nice. Can you hear me, George?
Nope. Nope. So
yeah.
That was really interesting, actually. This I mean,
if you had mentioned that sooner, we'd probably
had about a twenty minute chat on the
client side of Valuer. But I don't wanna
keep you too much longer. But it that
made me wonder, could we be in a
position six,
nine, twelve months from now, right, where
my front end application
using WebAssembly,
most likely, just pulls the OCIR effect with
the flags itself and evaluates everything in browser.
Or even
instead of me hosting Flipt somewhere,
can I just embed it maybe free of
web assembly again
into any application and have the evaluator pull
the OCIR effect for me in a regular
interval? Like, I have I think that opens
up a lot of different
runtime applications for Flipt that we just haven't
really seen before. I don't know if there's
something that that people would be interested in
or want. But
if
I could, I'd probably try it. Right? Yeah.
%.
Yeah. I mean and, yeah, not to not
to make this go any longer, but we
oh oh, sorry. I didn't mean that in
negative.
On the Wasm front,
we have played around with you know how,
like, I showed, I briefly showed, like, configuring
the rules in the UI or, you know,
you can do the same with,
with,
YAML.
Like, what if users could write their own
evaluation rules
in a language of their choice? Those compiled
to Wasm. The evaluator
then prox out to that that evaluation time.
So you're not limited to just the the
the pieces that we expose in our UI.
You can use, you know, any language to
define your rules and your rollout strategy.
Alright. I'm gonna push this a little bit
longer because there's too much here. But this
is not your roadmap roadshow for
Just because you're talking about using languages to
define what those evaluations are. Right? We're talking
about expressions
and, like, you're writing in Go, which means
you're probably in quite a nice position to
support something like Sell, like the common expression
language, allowing people to rate arbitrary queries against
that as well. And I think I've just
there's just so many ideas, man. I could
stay here for hours and just talk about
all the cool things I would like to
try with this. But I think that is
definitely a session for another day. So what
I'll do is we'll we'll look back, right,
early next year. We'll see where Flipt is
and and talk about some some fun stuff
we could do.
Alright. George, it's been a not so much
a pleasure, Mark, thank you for joining.
Thanks for having us, David. We really appreciate
it. Alright. Now
it's the end.
I'm gonna have the end broadcast button. But
just to make it a little bit more
fun, the pause is gonna be held in
eternity and potentially in the screenshot
for this thumbnail. So as I end, prepare
yourselves,
stay static, and we'll see you all next
time. Thanks.